alright division players get your
crafting and resource conversions in
before the April twelfth update because
the division is getting a whole lot
grandeur the new increase in cost for
converting material is doubling from
green standard materials to blue
specialized materials and tripling from
blue specialized to gold high-end
materials in addition deconstructing
high-end items will now only yield half
of the resources as for the carrot
players are getting new high-end
blueprints and a few new name weapons
including the warlord assault rifle and
valkyria submachine gun on the plus side
recalibrating high-end items will now
cost normal credits instead of Phoenix
credit players can also look forward to
earning for new gear sets from quote the
most challenging activities in Manhattan
also in the update DZ gear is getting a
lot more accessible for casual players
players will be able to purchase purple
gear at DZ rank 15 instead of 30 gold
level 30 gear at DZ rank 25 instead of
50 and gold level 31 gear at DZ rank 40
instead of 50 and you thought
procrastination didn't pay off the
update also finally clarifies how gear
score is associated with armor level
high-end armor level 30 results in a
gear score of 163 whereas high-end armor
level 31 yields a gear score of 182 for
reference the new incursion requires a
minimum gear score of 150 how do you
feel about the upcoming incursion update
will hesitant players venture into the
DZ well high level players turn in their
rakes and hoes because the farming left
just isn't worth it anymore leave your
thoughts in the comments below and for
more coverage of the division stay tuned
to gamespot com
you